corse nouvelle série d'attentats les
indépendantistes continuent de défier le
gouvernement
nice toulouse marseille et inter europe
une vue sur un système de navettes
continue entre ces villes et pack cinéma
daniel auteuil patrick timsit sont nos
invités ce soir pour la sortie du film
passage à la rue daniel auteuil dans le
rôle d'un psychanalyste et patrick
timsit dans celui d'un tueur en série on
en prend série par nous on en parlera
tout à l'heure il me trouble madame
monsieur bonsoir les organisations
clandestines corses continuent de défier
le gouvernement français en l'espace de
72 heures elles ont tiré une roquette
contre une caserne de gendarmes c'était
vendredi soir la nuit dernière elles ont
recommencé mitraillant une façade de
gendarmerie et faisant exploser une
bombe à l'intérieur d'un établissement
pénitentiaire une bombe qui a fait des
dégâts très importants
alban nicosie lucien têtu pulvérisé le
réfectoire du personnel de la prison de
casabianda complètement détruite les
cuisines les dégâts sont ici très
important vers 3 heures du matin une
explosion d'une grande violence a
réveillé des riverains j'ai entendu un
gros bruit pas une déflagration
tout de suite je me suis dirigée vers la
fenêtre de la salle de bain et j'ai pu
constater qu'il y avait de la fumée qui
se dégageait du toile du metz qui seront
en jeu à vingt mètres au dessus de chez
moi je me suis avancé j'ai senti une
grosse odeur de soufre ont jailli bon
match c'est bon j'ai compris tout de
suite
la charge explosive était semble-t-il
reliés à des bouteilles de gaz sans
doute prouver ici dans les cuisines le
bâtiment détruit fait partie des
cantonnements un peu à l'extérieur du
centre pénitentiaire proprement dit
casabianda est un site spécialisé ou 250
détenus vivent en semi-liberté mais le
centre reçoit aussi à l'occasion des
forces de l'ordre en mission sur l'île
il ya régulièrement une quarantaine de
personnes 1 qui viennent prendre leur
repas à se met donc en ce sens cela ils
sont forcément touchés parmi lesquels
des gendarmes oui il ya aussi donc
d'autres administrations qui ont
l'occasion d'autres fonctionnaires qui
peuvent venir prendre leur repas au mess
deux heures plus tôt c'est la
gendarmerie dole est un village à 25 km
de bastia qui a été mitraillé
une douzaine d'impacts ont été relevés
sur la porte et sur les garages les gars
ont aussi été infligées aux véhicules de
gendarmerie il n'y a pas de blessé cette
recrudescence des attentats 4 en 48
heures intervient alors que deux
nationalistes interpellés jeudi sont
toujours en garde à vue ils sont
considérés comme proches de la coume
colts à nationaliste la vitrine légale
du flnc canal historique
pour alain orsoni leader du npa un autre
mouvement autonomiste la spirale de
violence actuelle est très négative pour
lille nous avons fait le constat que la
violence politique clandestine
aujourd'hui est rejeté par l'immense
majorité du peuple corse qu'elle va à
l'encontre des intérêts de ce peuple et
qu'elle va y compris à l'encontre des
intérêts du nationalisme cox lui même de
lourds nuages s'amoncellent ce soir sur
la corse les attentats de la nuit n'ont
pas encore été revendiqué mais
l'ambiance reste tendue
j'ajoute que pour le ministre de
l'intérieur jean louis debré la
politique de fermeté du gouvernement
doit se poursuivre pour lui il n'y aura
pas de progrès social pour les corses il
n'ya pas rétablissement de l'état de
droit et de l'ordre public dans l'île
enfin sur les douze personnes
interpellées jeudi dernier dans le cadre
de l' enquête sur la mairie de bordeaux
il restait aujourd'hui deux personnes en
garde à vue deux frères l'un a été
relâché le second déférés devant le juge
antiterroriste laurence le vert à paris
du nouveau en france à partir de demain
dans le domaine du transport aérien air
inter europe lance se lance dans un
trafic continue entre paris nice
toulouse et marseille un système de
navettes toutes les demi heures avec
formalités d'embarquement réduites à
leur plus simple expression
alice le trafic sera un peu plus plus
long une heure chaque avion un avion
toutes les heures seulement yasmina
farber didier bon nouvel accueil
nouveaux horaires d'hiver sur air inter
europe avec 1 million 800 mille
passagers par an
la ligne nice orly vient d'entrer dans
le programme navette trente vols
aller-retour toutes les heures à partir
de 7 heures 10 le matin
un rythme habituel à nice avec quelques
changements que vous avez mal
enregistrement choisir votre siège
de plus vous avez une relation accord
pour que ce soit un système souple où il
n'y ait pas de retard qu'on puisse
prendre l'avion qu'on désire et
rapidement quoi qu'ils voient de retard
comme on a l'habitude de voir moins de
bousculade pour avoir la meilleure place
à bord un siège est attribué d'office
les habitués reconnaîtront très vite
leurs portes d'embarquement
elle ne changera plus selon les vols
pour être plus ponctuels la compagnie
modifie son organisation entre le
débarquement des arrivants et
l'embarquement des passagers
il devrait s'écouler au maximum 40
minutes alors qu'avant ce demi-tour
s'effectuer en 50 minutes
une petite collation le respect des
horaires le programme navette veut
trouver une vitesse de croisière plus
moderne
c'est un produit qui n'est pas finalisé
aujourd'hui qui va se sont rodés petit à
petit qui va s'améliorer des nouveaux
services vont être offerts aux passagers
vous allez avoir des banques
d'enregistrement automatique vous allez
avoir des banques de vente de billets
automatique
pour le moment la navette n'est pas
encore un avion taxi attention pour les
retardataires l'enregistrement ferment
plus tôt il risque d'être orienté vers
le vol suivant
mais si le produit est efficace la
compagnie espère reconquérir à nice une
clientèle lassé par les retards et le
manque de services et grignoter à ses
concurrents 8 % de nouveaux passagers
après l'effondrement d'une tribune du
cirque zavatta jeudi dernier à
valenciennes idia zavatta propriétaire
du cirque a été mise en examen pour
blessures involontaires la justice
s'interroge également sur le nombre de
places autorisées pour cette
représentation
on parle de 1200 enfants présents alors
qu'il n'y avait que 700 places
réglementaire philippe visseyrias gens
du québec
ce chapiteau ne pouvait accueillir que
700 personnes or au moment du drame il y
avait 1200 enfants sur ses gradins les
consignes de la commission de sécurité
n'ont donc pas été respectées c'est la
première découverte des enquêteurs
lydia zavatta la propriétaire du cirque
et son compagnon ont été mises en examen
hier soir pour blessures involontaires
aujourd'hui même dans le milieu du
cirque on commence à dénoncer la
surcharge des gradins une pratique
apparemment très courante
ce qu'il faut surtout savoir c'est que
vous avez beaucoup de petites structures
qui pendent des noms prestigieux qui
étaient des structures qui accueillait
généralement 200 300 400 500 600 places
au grand maximum et qui parce qu'elles
pensent ce grand nom mais plus de monde
à l'intérieur donc rajoute certainement
des protéines bardin ce jour où j'ai un
contrôle eh ben j'ai dit que j'avais 300
places et où leur essence le main dans
la poche
il existe en france plusieurs circuits
avatar l'un d'entre eux est en
représentation cet après midi à paris
cette fois ci les gradins n'était pas
plein
williams à bata le propriétaire n'est
autre que le frère de lydia il réfute
les accusations du président du syndicat
ce monsieur dit qu'on fait pour rentrer
plus de gens que la capacité normale
est ce que vous en pensez
rien
sipa c'est pas possible on peut pas
mettre les gens les uns sur les autres
la ville de valenciennes a décidé
d'annuler toutes les autres
représentations prévues au programme
l'accident de vendredi n'a heureusement
fait que quelques blessés légers mais la
justice interdit désormais à lydia
zavatta de diriger un autre cirque
jusqu'à nouvel ordre
l'actualité internationale au zaïre dans
le nord-est du pays très exactement la
situation s'est encore détériorée
aujourd'hui l'armée zaïroise est aux
prises avec des rebelles d'origine tutsi
l'armé du rwanda voisine serait
également intervenu et au milieu de ces
combats près de cinq cent mille réfugiés
de l'ethnie rival hutus qui ont fui les
camps où ils étaient installés tout cela
sans aucune chance de secours désormais
dans la mesure où les organisations
humanitaires internationales ont fait
évacuer la quasi totalité de leur
personnel sur place
françois cante fuyons leur camp attaqué
pour certains à l'armé lourde sur la
frontière aéro rwandaise plusieurs
milliers de réfugiés hutus originaire du
rwanda ont quitté aujourd'hui goma au
nord-est du zaïre évacués par le haut
commissariat des nations unies pour les
réfugiés
c'est au tour tourne malgré les risques
de représailles au rwanda qu'ils avaient
quittée voici deux ans après le génocide
contre les tutsi d'autres réfugiés
quelque 200000 to her depuis plusieurs
jours sur la frontière entre bukavu et
goma san jose la franchir et c'est de
trouver refuge dans des camps saturé
privés de nourriture et de médicaments
un nouvel exode proche du désastre
humanitaire selon le hcr
mille tonnes de nourriture sont bloqués
pendant ce temps dans ses camions du
programme alimentaire mondial à la
frontière entre l'ouganda et le nord du
zaïre
plus personne ne passe les organisations
humanitaires rapatrient leurs
représentants au zaïre vers l'ouganda
les sens sans aide aucune les camps de
réfugiés hutus
à bukavu la situation devrait ma taille
douce il comme les bd ce qu'il ya de
vraiment bouleversant seco sur la route
de l'aéroport
nous avons eu des centaines et des
centaines de réfugiés marché la
désespérée et le regarder partir à
l'origine de ce nouveau chaos qui ramène
ces réfugiés hutus à la case départ au
rwanda le conflit qui oppose dans l'est
du zaïre les tutsis de souche installés
depuis deux siècles dans le pays et
l'armée zaïroise kinshasa accuse le
rwanda dont les armées sont dominée par
l'ethnie tutsie d'épauler la rébellion
au zaïre rebelles qui serait sur le
point de s'emparer de la ville d'uvira
et qui ont atteint ce soir bukavu
objectifs de la rébellion empêcher les
hutus en exil au zaïre de se réarmer et
de revenir en force au rwanda pour
affronter le pouvoir tutsi
le pape jean paul ii a célébré ce matin
sa première messe à saint pierre de rome
depuis son opération de l'appendicite
c'était au début du mois d'octobre
le saint père a également salué et
parler aux milliers de fidèles
rassemblés ce matin donc à rome sur
l'esplanade du vatican
auparavant il avait comme je voulais dit
président est célébré un office au
vatican
c'était tôt au mois de juillet dernier
pendant durant les jeux olympiques
d'atlanta une bombe explosait souvenez
vous dans le parc d'attraction de la
ville faisant deux morts et 118 blessé
un employé richard jewel était d'abord
féliciter pour avoir prévenu la police
puis accusé d'avoir posé la bombe vient
aujourd'hui il est totalement innocenté
par les policiers du fbi à et philippe
gassot le cauchemar de richard g où elle
a pris fin c'est ainsi que le quotidien
le washington post a présenté la lettre
de deux pages envoyée aux suspects par
le gouvernement américain et qui
l'innocentent nous ne croyons pas écrit
l'avocat du département de la justice
que vous ayez fait cela sous-entendu
poser une bombe
atlanta pendant les jeux pourtant cet
ancien employé de la sécurité est resté
au centre de la cible des suspects
pendant près de trois mois
ce collectionneur d'armes célibataire
qui habite chez sa maman a vu sa vie
basculer
entre presse et perquisitions
interrogatoires et interviews le fbi
n'avait qu'un suspect lui vous savez
pourquoi vous est suspecté non je ne
sais pas du tout vous avez fait non
monsieur je n'ai pas fait ça ils avaient
été vus tout près du lieu de l'explosion
quelques minutes avant qu'elle ne se
produise
cela a suffi pour placer jiwei sous le
feu des projecteurs de la police et de
la presse jeter en pâture aux médias les
plus puissants du monde
il faudra du temps maintenant pour que
l'honneur perdu d'un ancien vigile lui
soit rendue mais on sait que de la
calomnie
il reste toujours quelque chose le fbi a
et va maintenant devoir trouver
quelqu'un d'autre pour richard gere
welte ça n'est pas terminé il pourrait
engager un procès puis la rédaction de
ses mémoires donc obtenir quelques
millions de dollars
en bref encore élection présidentielle
aujourd'hui en bulgarie les communistes
réformateurs qui avait repris le pouvoir
dans le pays sont en passe d'être battu
le candidat d'opposition de droite
arriverait ce soir largement en tête en
france après la journée massif central
mort c'était vendredi dernier des
éleveurs ont mis en place un nouveau
barrage filtrant ce soir près d'ambert
dans le puy de dôme
toujours dans le même souci de faire
pression sur les ministres européens de
l'agriculture réunis à partir de demain
à bruxelles pour débattre de nouvelles
aides éventuelles aux producteurs de
bovins touchés par la crise de la vache
folle politique jean pierre chevènement
avait réuni son mouvement des citoyens
aujourd'hui à saint nazaire il a été
réélu à sa tête jean pierre chevènement
toujours aussi négatif à l'égard du
traité européen de maastricht et qui
envisage de proposer un nouveau
référendum aux français sur le thème de
la monnaie unique guilaine chenu eric de
lannion ils repartent au combat avec
quelques milliers de fiches en 92 ils
ont fait campagne pour le non
triste quatre ans plus tard ils veulent
un nouveau référendum comprends que
beaucoup de français rouen vous changé
d'avis depuis
depuis un certain temps étant donné ses
droits ce qui se passe avec le traité de
maastricht au mouvement des citoyens en
est mais démonstration par l'exemple des
victimes de privatisation
délocalisations sont venus dire tout le
mal qu'il pense de maastricht
il y a aussi des pasionaria comme noël
green de l'entreprise l'épée évacués par
les crs il ya deux mois
et il ya enfin un mentor jean pierre
chevènement le projet de maastricht
aujourd'hui débouche sur la perspective
d'une monnaie unique réduite à un
moignon d'europe autour de l'allemagne
c'est à dire sur l'absorption du franc
par le marque un pays qui renonce à sa
monnaie au profit d'un autre plus
puissants perd sa liberté
la disparition du franc sera aussi celle
de la france le référendum a peu de
chances de voir le jour mais cette
campagne permet à jean pierre
chevènement et ses amis de faire
entendre leur voix et peser sur la
gauche à l'heure où elle se prépare à
faire l'union pour les législatives de
98 françois léotard le président du bief
ce soir sur la première chaîne
souhaiterait que le président de la
république dans les mois qui viennent
procède soit un remaniement du
gouvernement ou encore une dissolution
de l'assemblée nationale ou encore
prennent l'initiative dit il d'un
référendum
alcatel qui vient de rater le rachat de
thomson annonce aujourd'hui 16 cents
suppressions d'emplois dans sa filiale
télécom d'ici à la fin de l'année 98
dans un souci de compétitivité
internationale annonce la direction en
revanche aucune fermeture de site net à
envisager cette semaine va à s'ouvrir à
marseille a un immense complexe
commercial installé en plein coeur des
quartiers les plus pauvres de la ville
marseille nord il a fallu une dizaine
d'années pour que ce projet se réalise
avec la garantie pour quelques centaines
de jeunes de la ville y trouver un
emploi patrice blais et mène ventech
accrochées aux collines des quartiers
nord un paquebot de la consommation 200
boutiques et un hypermarché
près de 1200 emplois au pied des cités
marseillaise majid vient tout juste
d'être embauchés sélectionnés parmi sept
mille candidatures
la grande distribution a toujours été
son objectif à 26 ans un contrat à durée
indéterminée fait de lui un homme
heureux comme tout jeune on a des
projets on a la jeunesse on veut faire
un foyer on a beaucoup de projets tout
ça passe par toi et tu sais quoi
sylvie elle a beaucoup galéré à 30 ans
est la plus connue le chômage que le
travail aujourd'hui elle est vendeuse 25
heures par semaine payées environ 10%
au-dessus du smic
un retour à l'emploi après des années
d'inactivité vous avez cherché combien
de temps j'ai juste quatre ans j'ai
juste trouvé dans sa cité magique fait
figure de privilégiés à la bricarde le
chômage dépasse les 50% grand littoral à
favoriser les embauches locales 800
environ sur marseille mais dans les
quartiers nord bien des jeunes sont
déçus à la veille de l'inauguration il
manque beaucoup d'emplois pour apaiser
les cités qui n'a pas d'amis
on n'a pas d'argent qui cherchent à s'en
sortir et qui n'arrive pas ici en plus
il a par exemple sylvie parle de chance
d'avoir trouvé un temps partiel elle
espère un jour faire 39 heures par
semaine avec un salaire plein mais cela
dépendra de la réussite économique de
cette cité de la consommation la nuit
dernière nous avons changé d'heure nous
sommes désormais donc en horaires
d'hiver un changement plus facile dans
les villes que dans les campagnes comme
nous l'avons constaté ce matin dans une
exploitation agricole du nord de la
france mariam masse patrick bach
ce matin les vaches de monsieur raviart
on tue un quart d'heures de sommeil en
rab
le changement d'heure il a choisi de
l'étaler sur quelques jours pour ne pas
perturber ces demoiselles surtout au
niveau des horaires de travail vont en
manger toute la journée ou laqué genre
d'être actifs ont décalé et bon an mal
an je pense pas que la production est
perturbé pourquoi changer pour les
animaux comme d habitude les plus
perturbés dans leur habitude ce sont
encore les veaux ce matin le petit
déjeuner est arrivé avec une heure de
retard
on entendait presque les estomacs
gargouilles et ils sont peu décalé plus
brutalement parce que c'est mon épouse
qui s'en occupe en général est bon
shopping
des enfants entre 2 donc réguler il est
7h30 heure d'hiver le jour se lève la
traite est presque terminée et déjà les
premiers habitués du village viennent
chercher leur ration de l'est du
dimanche un peu perturbée aussi je
préfère leur de maintenant lord
aujourd'hui habitués à se faire la queue
leu leu 2 heures flèche est trop bas les
questions traitées je ne sais pas où il
est donc là lors de la traite est
terminé il est quelle heure à votre
montre devant la guerre n'est pas
changer votre nom bapt est une question
d'habitude je changerais peut-être
demain sûrement mais aujourd'hui j'avais
pas changé dès demain il faudra se
remettre à l'heure pour le laitier et
pour tous les autres impératifs de la
vie des exploitants à la campagne on
préfère quand même leurs divers plus en
adéquation avec la nature à espelette et
dans une partie de la montagne du pays
basque c'était aujourd'hui la fête du
piment à l'occasion de la récolte de
l'année des festivités hautes en
couleurs principalement rouge de la
couleur du piment françois privat fils
hybride
les bandas ce emblème absolu du pays
basque rythme la fête du piment
d'espelette laisse pélata commis pétards
comme on dit ici un bilan rapporté par
les conquistadors espagnols après la
conquête de l'amérique centrale est
aujourd'hui chacun fait son marché
l'envers du décor des champs de piment
tout autour du village
cette culture en pleine expansion
s'étale sur les trois quarts de l'année
et constitue une bonne activité
complémentaire pour une petite
exploitation agricole
en attendant peut être mieux les
familles de vivre à l'aise vient qu'avec
des paiements mais je vais faire une
quantité assez suffisante aux alentours
de 60 mille pieds et avec ça je pense
qu'ils pouvaient tout se passe donc en
famille et le plus souvent dans la salle
à manger de la ferme chaque piment et
méticuleusement triés par formes tailles
et qualité avant d'être placés sur des
cordes puis il sèche durant plusieurs
semaines sur les façades des maisons
basques avant un séjour de quelques
heures dans un four à pain ce pignon a
été rentrée dans le four ce matin vers 4
heures de cela pour
en lever son immunité résiduelle ensuite
il fera passer par un concasseur pour
être broyés une poudre de piment utilisé
comme du poivre pour relever le goût de
la shoah le plat d'espelette tu mélanges
vos oignons et piment bien sûr par
rapport à l'image d'une fille en bande
toujours cayenne trait pour trait du
camp y il est simplement gentiment
pickens et qui voudrait oublier un petit
peu de chaleur dans le palais mais comme
quelque chose d'agréable houlette du feu
tout l'après midi
mais il a surtout du goût et du parfum
en attendant les producteurs du pays
basque souhaite la mise en place d'une
appellation d'origine contrôlée pour que
seuls espelette car ça fait partie du
folklore espagnol à la même époque
chaque année la capitale madrid est
envahie par des milliers de moutons qui
venant des pâturages du nord où ils ont
séjourné pendant l'été traverse donc la
ville pour gagner ceux du sud où ils
vont passer tranquillement
l'hiver il ya quelques instants on était
en pleine saison de récolte des piments
revanche sache elle celle des
champignons comme chaque année elle a
donné lieu à quelques affrontements
entre cueilleurs et propriétaires c'est
dans un souci d'apaisement dirons-nous
qu'une association de propriétaires
justement de la région de castres
propose aux citadins des sorties
organisées et encadrées christophe
laroque olivier combe
mettez vous une seconde dans la peau
d'un champignon
vu d'ici vous comprendrez sans doute
cette complainte un ramasseur de
champignons ça va 150
bonjour les dégâts c'est pourquoi dans
la montagne noire
une association de propriétaires
cherchent à aiguë et les promeneurs du
dimanche
là où il passe les champignons doivent
repousser et pour ça une seule règle il
faut protéger mycélium il faut
absolument respecter la partie
permanente du champignon qui s'appelle
le mycélium des filaments souterrain qui
ne supporte pas la lumière
donc il faut cueillir les champignons
sur le cueille avec son pied il faut
reboucher le trou c'est encore mieux
et là on aura des champions l'année
prochaine si la saison permet
les promeneurs n'y perdent pas au change
après une petite leçon de morale sur le
respect de la propriété d'autrui
on leur dévoile tous les mystères des
champignons comestibles ou non c'est
normalement il est violet partout et là
il a perdu ses couleurs
c'est la carrière et istina sage obligé
de ce type de visites le chapitre
concernant les champignons dangereuses
les colas réglé
chapillon avaient rejeté à cause de la
commission vous pouvez faire avec les
amanites phalloïdes il y en a pas mal
qui sont comestibles à kiki qui sont
comestibles donc je ne savais pas et ça
m'a permis d'apprendre aussi
indifférente
sauf que champignons qu'ils font à peu
près partie de la même famille de
variétés à l'issue de la visite les
propriétaires conclu un pacte avec les
ramasseurs de champignons
ceux ci seront bien accueillis s'ils
viennent le week-end les propriétaires
eux profiteront du reste de la semaine
un marché du mans scellé par une bonne
fricassée de champignons sport après les
défaites cinglantes hier en coupe
d'europe de rugby des équipes françaises
une équipe le ca brive a sauvé l'honneur
aujourd'hui en battant les harlequins de
londres 23 à 10 18e classique
internationale de course à pied entre
marseille et cassis une compétition qui
a le grand avantage tout au long de ces
20 km et un peu plus de traverser les
plus beaux paysages de france christelle
bertrand dominique bonnet marseille
marseille
encore quelques minutes d'arrêt pour
plus de 12 mille coureurs impatients
derrière la grille de départ ils veulent
tous aller à leur allure ils vont tous y
aller à cassis c'est parti pour 20 km
300 de course pour les uns et de balade
pour les autres ils viennent de belgique
de pologne de tanzanie ou de hongrie
pour courir d'abord dans les rues de
marseille et rencontrer un public aux
anges
et du courage il en faut surtout quand
il fait chaud et quand ça monte alors
dans des conditions difficiles tout le
monde s'aide avant de faire une petite
pause pour se désaltérer le croisty
d'autres fous les deux en même temps
mais quand la pause est terminée il faut
repartir surtout garder le bon rythme au
fil des kilomètres
ils sont passés par ici chez ge laban
est déjà passé par là c'est sa deuxième
victoire avec en prime le record de
l'épreuve derrière ils sont bien loin du
kenyan plusieurs milliers de coureurs
ont mis plus de deux heures et demie
mais peu importe le chronomètre
ils ont pris le temps de profiter du
paysage
l'arrivée sur le port de cassis annonce
la fin d'une rude épreuve même pour ce
coureur qui a vu le coureur qui a vu
l'homme c'était très dur plus très chaud
un jeu sur votre pas combien pour
arriver au bout d'autres ont choisi la
prière de finir la course il va nuire et
tout ça de courir de courir aussi le
confie c'est pas mal de gens et oui le
miracle a bien eu lieu
on s'est baigné à cassis 1 27 octobre
l'événement sportif de la semaine à
venir c'est à bercy le tennis réunissant
les plus grands champions du moment
aujourd'hui à la veille de la
compétition
plusieurs d'entre eux étaient venus
donner un coup de main à yannick noah et
à son association les enfants de la
terre françois brabant mike richards
c'est bien connu le tennis est un jeu
d'enfant et pour les enfants de la terre
des enfants qui viennent avait partout à
bercy cet après midi jusque sur la
chaise d'andrea guest bref ça a beau
être les vacances
bercy ressemble à une vraie cour de
récréation
c'est la première fois que les knicks
noir occupent merci à la veille du
tournoi pour récolter des fonds pour son
association forcément une première
farran un peu nerveux d'autant qu'en
face ils s'y sont mis à plusieurs et qu'
ils sont pas là pour rigoler
nous aussi à chercher de l'aide dans le
public depuis les tribunes wilfried
m'arrêtais pas de conseil et non à lui a
demandé donc de le rejoindre sur le
court et il n'a pas eu à le regretter
à eux deux yannick et wilfrid battre on
guette un nouveau tandem au plus haut
niveau
signé il faut craindre à la fédération
mais on ne sait pas s'il peut répondre
est-ce que tu me donnes bah moi ça ne
serait pas de problème sur tout câble en
ce moment chez j'ai préparé tout un
programme
c'est un programme surtout si avec l'âge
demain les choses sérieuses pourront
commencer bercy c'est le tournoi le plus
riche du monde le plus important de
cette fin de saison furent courrier
hedberg boetsch et les autres mais
aujourd'hui le moins le tennis est
redevenu ce qu'il aurait dû toujours
être un jeu d'enfant
si les mains daniel auteuil patrick
timsit sont invités ce soir pour la
sortie du film de francis girod passage
à l'acte l'histoire d'un psychanalyste
aux prises avec un tueur en série pascal
deschamps eric georges le véritable
héros c'est le divan d'antoine rivières
on y fait de bien curieuses révélations
on patiente qui ont avec un analyste
j'ose imaginer ma profession la routine
en quelque sorte jusqu'au jour où enfin
les morts quand c'est quelque chose
c'est moins qu'il ait tué
alors que 20 psychanalystes quand même
ses patients lui avouer un crime
autant il ya eu des films à placer dans
des glaciers qui d'ailleurs était une
cible différente de celle afghan france
autant
pourquoi qu'il ya les films c'est
vraiment vraiment dans les analyses
délire schizophrène ou provocation entre
le praticien et le patient commence
alors un drôle de jeu dont le meneur
mais pas forcément celui qu'on croit
qu'est-ce qu'il faut parfois dépenser
comme énergie pour faire trier j'avais
beau m'énerver la gifle et il n'y avait
rien à faire pour lui arracher autre
chose quand on jubile l'appartement
serait plus suffire mais pas dans une
ville et faire entendre à des voisins de
pavillons ou paire de gifles un
gémissement même long c'est pas possible
monsieur bergues je crois que ça suffit
maintenant il faut que je poursuive le
psy va alors être contraint de quitter
pour la première fois les 12 m² feutré
de son cabinet pour mener l enquête
abandonnant ainsi la neutralité
bienveillante à laquelle sa fonction le
limite non sans risque à l'eau ce qui
est né ici comme un vrai touristes ont
dû iard crâne rasé petites lunettes
dorées jean bofane pelo ballotté entre
mensonge et vérité c'est le
psychanalyste se referme le piège
un peu comme sur le prêtre du film
d'hitchcock la loi du silence mais ne
dit on pas aujourd'hui que le divan a
remplacé le confessionnal
sa demie ça donnait envie oui oui parce
qu'il ya des scènes de sexe
on nous a dit que le sexe était
préventeur donc mais eux mais quand même
les scènes de sexe je peux dire quelque
chose
c'est sur les scènes de sexe uniquement
daniel houghton les artistes sont des
gens parfois particulier ce que vous
étiez déjà fait psychanalyse et avances
non jamais jamais et non non mais en
revanche je trouve à analyser c'est
encore plus curieux parce que c'est on
apprend des drôles de choses sur soi et
sur les autres vous avez observé des
professionnels à vendre et l'inde
j'aime en incarnant un psychanalyste si
j'étais parti d'un principe un peu
facile et c'est à dire que les les
patients sont dans le dos d analyse et d
analyse ans donc il ne les voit jamais
ton que je me suis dis simplement qu'il
fallait avoir une écoute particulière
c'est tout moi j'ai parlé avec gérard
muller beaucoup qui a écrit les
dialogues et les psychanalystes etc et
psychanalyste et qui donne donc la
caution de tous les psychanalystes sur
ce film c'est un film totalement
crédible en tout cas au niveau de ce qui
se passe à 6 alors contrairement à vous
ce soir je veux dire c'est pas un film
drôle patrick jean type n'auriez pas osé
dramatique c'est d'ailleurs la première
qu'on n'a pas pris de plaisir non c'est
la première fois que vous incarnez un
personnage allait dire sérieux au cinéma
oui mais bachar je crache accord avec
vous
elle mettrait pas dans le giro ça vous
fait penser à daniel auteuil parce que
daniel auteuil avait joué dans manon des
sources et
jean de florette vous étiez vous aussi
un acteur de films plutôt comique numéro
6 et vous avez changé de changer de
registre à cette occasion là vous avez
l'intention de changer de registre plus
facile c'est plus difficile c'est plus
intéressant je repartirai dans la
comédie puisque j'ai des projets de
comédie donc c'est vraiment pas changé
c'est c'est uniquement parce que j'ai vu
d'abord c'est un scénario c'est quand
même un film policier quoi un fellah
voilà parce que ma reprocher de dire
thriller frais et psychologique et quand
j'ai eu le scénario c'est vraiment j'ai
vraiment fonctionné avec l'histoire et
après c'est vrai que le personnage est
sérieux et on n'a pas raconté la fin
parce que c'est un film qui repose non
mais à la fa sur le suspense
cela dit vous êtes vous un tueur en
série alors c'est un personnage drôle
c'est le début we say say say say un jeu
du chat et la souris jeu sera pas facile
c'est bien donc on ne sait pas si si
c'est un fantasme un délire d'impatience
c'est pour ça qu'il doit mener les
enquêtes ou si il a réellement exécutées
toutes ces personnes dont il parle
daniel c'est un c'est un huit clos
pratiquement entre vous et patrick
timsit
c'est un film qu'on a sans doute on a
l'impression qu'on a du mal à le jouer
vous êtes dont vous êtes assis vous avez
un rôle comme ça très très statique est
ce que c'est pas compliqué de jouer
c'est pas un rêve dans lequel on peut
s'extraire y aurait une âme à 6 c'est à
dire que c'est statique jusqu'au mot
juste jusqu'au moment où
l'action dans fage où notre rapport
devient tellement insupportable que vous
savez de l'aisselle les scènes des
analyses dans ce film sont des scènes
extrêmement violente c'est à dire que à
chaque moment se demande si si on va pas
se sauver de support pour s'étriper
c'est sur les scènes qui font avancer
l'action est très très vite très très
vite nous allons nous allons laisser
derrière deux heures quarante trois
heures de film
non non c'est ça devient très vite un
film un film policier de pour semer mais
c'est quoi votre question peut-être dire
quelque chose de pas qui reviennent sur
le faire le barça tv
non mais parce qu'on peut on annoncer
que rester assis nous et que c'était
quoi la question bon match et yann sauvé
sur le sur le rôle difficile à jouer
dans un avion c'est sa base basé sur du
dialogue quoi il ya pas beaucoup de abc
la base et autre métier d'acteur que de
dire merci d'avoir répondu à ma question
patrick timsit je vous posais une
question qui n'a rien à voir avec le
film j'ai lu où j'ai entendu dire que
vous prépariez un one man show parce que
vous êtes un humoriste a commis et vous
dites c'est le dernier parce qu'après je
serai trop vieux mais je pensais mais en
même temps ça fait que c'est bien ça
fait bouger non ainsi pour m'encourager
sûrement à l'écrire en ce moment comme
ça comme je suis persuadé que c'est le
dernier je vais y mettre le paquet et on
va le faire entièrement nouveau et mais
le ton en fait qu'on emploie parce que
je ne suis pas tout seul à l'écrire avec
bruno gaccio jean françois halin et
franck magnier manier le dernier les
guignols c'est vrai que c'est un ton où
on est encore dans le coup je sais pas
s'ils n'ont plus tard voilà parler de sa
femme par la société comme ça on sera
pas un petit peu largués mais si
messieurs dernière que c'est notre
invitation donc passage à l'acte le film
va sortir cette semaine sur les écrans
dans quelques instants la météo laurent
romejko 20h50 notre série urgences le
dernier journal aux alentours de minuit
florence dauchez 7h50 demain dans les 4
vérités
gérard leclerc à sauvera ségolène royal
député socialiste je vous retrouve
demain à 20 heures je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée sur la prochaine
bonsoir messieurs bonsoir bonsoir